well the British Prime Minister Boris
Johnson is coming to Berlin today to try
to persuade Chancellor Merkel to reopen
brexit negotiations Johnson is calling
for the so called backstop for the Irish
border to be scrapped but so far
EU leaders have rejected those calls the
backstop is an insurance policy to avoid
a hard border between Northern Ireland
which is of course part of the UK and
the Republic of Ireland but it would
involve Northern Ireland remaining in
the EU customs union which Johnson's
claims would be a violation of British
sovereignty and the fear is that a hard
border on the island of Ireland would
reignite the decades of conflict known
as the troubles
GWS teri Schultz reports from Northern
Ireland's capital Belfast one of the
most popular activities these days for
visitors to Belfast is a troubles tour
we had 137 people hospitalized there
were horrific injuries
there were people multiple loss of limbs
guides like Paul Donnelly navigate
what's called a history of terror but
many fear history could be repeated
deadly clashes between Protestants
supporters of British rule and Catholics
180 unite with the Republic of Ireland
were largely ended two decades ago by a
power-sharing deal known as the Good
Friday Agreement but now the looming
prospect of a No Deal brexit could mean
the return of checkpoints along the
Irish border and that has people like
Donnelly warning that former anti
British guerrillas known as dissident
republicans might abandon the peace
process that's the danger of a hard
border it gives different Republicans
and contemporary justification but for
their advance you know it's not just
ideological it's saying this isn't
abstract anymore you look at those posts
along that border this is deferentially
what they see is this part of Ireland
from the rest of the end
you know I'm there worries over a hard
border and the loss of other EU rights
are compelling even some former pro
British loyalists to consider the once
unthinkable uniting Northern Ireland and
the Republic of Ireland the Good Friday
Agreement means Northern Ireland can
take a vote on doing just that
Belfast new Lord Mayor John Finnegan
wants to make sure citizens are well
educated about their options while
hoping they'll back unification' his
party Shin fain openly lobbies for that
it's a cause that coloured his life he
was just nine years old when he saw his
father a prominent Republican human
rights lawyer shot dead by pro British
paramilitaries despite getting death
threats himself as he took office in May
the Neukom believes the time is right to
move forward no deed brexit doesn't
automatically mean that unification will
happen but what I do think is that it
means that the conversation has to
happen because the conversation has
already started not just from people
within the north but people all over the
island of Ireland and certainly within
Europe as well
fifty years after the bloodiest period
in Northern Ireland's history a time
when we realized by so many walls and
gates around this city no one I spoke
with believes that addressing the
question of a united Ireland now would
lead the country back into that kind of
sectarian conflict at the same time no
one is completely confident it won't
Billy Hutchinson a city council member
from the progressive unionist party
served 16 years in prison for two
sectarian murders Hutchinson says he's
rejected violence but he's worried
others haven't what I'm concerned about
is the people will try to use a result
from brexit and a result from the
reporter pull as an excuse to start
another war at Queen's University
Belfast professor Colin Harvey says
people are anxious about the possible
impact of unification but also
frustrated with Britain the British
government has behaved recklessly
and irresponsibly in relation to this
region for some time people look at
what's happened and bretton their own
browser and it's been a let's be honest
it's been a shambolic utter disaster
Smith's that the British system seems to
be falling apart and I think there's a
real feeling on this island that we need
to maturely and sensibly manage and plan
a conversation and whatever the outcome
is you know find a sort of agreed way
forward recent surveys suggest most
people in Northern Ireland prefer to
stay part of Britain for now but those
who want a united Ireland say that
they're in no hurry
expecting a chaotic brexit to help their
case that report by DW staring schultz
he joins us now from Brussels g'day
Atari a Boris Johnson he'll be in Berlin
in just a few hours to talk with the
German Chancellor is there still time
for negotiations October 31st is drawing
very close now well technically Brian
obviously we're at the end of August
there are a couple of months until
Johnson says the UK is leaving the
European Union deal or no deal
the question is really whether there's
any willingness and so far we haven't
seen any remember that he doesn't just
have to convince one leader or two
leaders all 27 EU leaders would have to
agree to reopen the withdrawal agreement
and none of them are willing to do that
at the moment okay you say there's no
movement on in terms of the EU but
before the meeting with Johnson we've
just heard what could be taken as a
possible signal for some kind of
movement from the German Chancellor
let's let's take a listen
if we get a practical arrangement on how
to preserve the Good Friday Agreement
while still defining the borders of the
European single market we would no
longer need the backstop this means we
will think about practical solutions if
you have the will to find solutions you
can do so quickly the European Union is
ready to do that but we do not need to
reopen the withdrawal agreement that's
the matter for the future relationship
and I think we will act together okay no
reopening negotiations as you mentioned
Terry but it looks like there could be
some room on the back
stop what do you make of that statement
mystically as you might be doing because
again all 27 EU leaders have to agree on
any arrangement and don't forget one of
those leaders is the Irish leader the
Irish Prime Minister and Ireland is
absolutely not going to agree to
anything that puts up a hard border if
there's any alternative which No Deal
doesn't leave any alternative for that
at the moment so I'm as curious as
anyone else to hear what Chancellor
Merkel might suggest as a solution to
this because if there was one if there
was an easy practical solution God knows
how many months we negotiated on this it
seems like we would have heard about
that by now okay so we'll have to find
out later today what that's all about
after the meeting here in Berlin
Johnson's heading to Paris for meeting
with mr. McCrone what can we expect
there it's interesting that Boris
Johnson is heading to France and Germany
before he visits his nearest neighbor of
Ireland but yeah this is an effort of
course to get the two arguably most
powerful leaders in the European Union
to signal that they are willing to
compromise to signal some some room for
maneuvering but at the moment neither of
them have done so and you just I'm sorry
to be repetitive but you just can't get
away from the fact that all 27 EU
leaders including the Irish leader would
have to be willing to make any sort of
compromise on the withdrawal agreement
and with Boris Johnson saying himself
that he's not going to to compromise and
with the British Parliament having
rejected that withdrawal agreement that
exists three times I think that there's
a lot of euphemistic statements going
around but I just don't see how there is
any room for compromise at the moment
and everything that I hear including in
Northern Ireland seems to be heading
towards a hard brexit and that means
possibly a hard border okay teri Schultz
versus in Brussels Terry thanks very
much